ravi de vous retrouver pour ce parfum
spécial consacré aux élections
régionales on va commenter naturellement
les résultats en ile-de-france dans le
reste de la france et puis s'interroger
sur les conséquences que donneront le
vôtre que donnera le vote des français
si conséquence il ya pour en parler
stéphane minson
jean-patrice très bien merci toujours
professeur à l'université de
versailles-saint-quentin toujours jean
luc barek voilà qu'est quitté les
fourneaux
j'ai juste là pour venir pour venir avec
nous vivons y avait du monde mais il ya
toujours du monde se joue facilement
vivable mustapha larbaoui ça va toujours
jeter dans le club de trappes toujours
pharmaciens et à jour est appelée à
jouer un rôle de plus en plus important
me semble-t-il dans le monde du football
semble-t-il vous ne vous ne commentez
pas un commentaire
charles lajoie dit toujours à la tête
des éditions la joie toujours et génère
alors je vous propose de commencer
peut-être par l'une de france puisque
après tout ça a été une des c'est une
surprise n'est pas une surprise en tout
cas un des changements
la tête de liste de la région puisque
valérie pécresse a pris le poste de
président de région les succèdent après
17 ans de gouvernance de gauche qu'est
ce que vous pour que vous analysez cette
victoire est ce que c'était elle la
bonne candidate et que est ce que claude
bartolone n'était pas le bon candidat
est ce que ces propos dernier moment sur
la race blanche l'on enlevait des voix
parce que ça s'est joué à très peu on
est à peu près à moins d'un an et demi
pour cent de différences entre les deux
listes qui veut commencer a lancé
stéphane enfin oui vous avez raison de
souligner que ça s'est joué à très peu
je crois soixante mille voix près il est
'vert' beaurieux un bon report
d'ailleurs
donc alors on se dit maintenant est-ce
que c'était le bon candidat et certains
disent finalement non mais ça c'est
quand même un peu facile de le dire
après oui ce qui est ce qui est juste je
crois c'est que cette cette dernière
semaine de campagne un peu hystériser de
manière assez artificiel sur on dit
bartolone a imputé à valérie pécresse
des termes qu'elle n'a pas prononcé
alors c'était sans doute un peu plus
subtil que cela mais la subtilité au
cours de cette dernière semaine n'est
pas finalement c'était là bas c'était
entendu il y avait en effet mais je
pense que ça a été enfin extrêmement
maladroite par le bartolone enfin une
maladresse ou un calcul il a pensé aux
jeunes et la politique comme ça c'est
difficile à mesurer mais je pense que ça
l'a plutôt desservi que ça lui a
rapporté les voit jouer versailles
neuilly contre le reste de
l'ile-de-france où le 9-3 contre le 7 8
ou 9 2 c'est pas d'une d'une très grande
me semble-t-il habilité pour qui prétend
l assemblée
alors peut-être qu'il y avait aussi un
besoin aussi de changement parce que ça
faisait du bien quand même 17 ans plaît
vous souhaitez au pouvoir en ile de
france a fait une campagne très
concrètes sur les sujets précis au
profit des transilien partir elle a fait
une campagne beaucoup plus vaste plus
tôt nationale jouant sur son image et
sur ce la fonction qu'il occupe en
qualité de président de l'assemblée
je trouve que pécresse était beaucoup
plus jeune lamballe dans sillon que deux
là étaient bartolone et on constate
aussi que il ya eu
meilleure proportion de votes sur le
deuxième tour puisque il ya eu moins
l'abstention ce qui est un signe et puis
le fonds national a perdu des voix y
avait certainement donc le front
national a perdu 4 points ce qui ne veut
pas dire d'ailleurs qu'ils se soient
tous se retrouver chez finalement les
faits lui parce que je sais pour elle le
regarde bien les résultats c'est pas le
cas
cependant il va les perdre et sur la
deuxième la dernière semaine a fait une
campagne très très forte et elle a évité
tous les écueils
alors que bartolone lui j'adore pour
faire une campagne d'image une campagne
secteur ya il est quand même une
question qui se pose est de débuter
bartolone a été un peu encore dit de
raccroc s'il doit y avoir des primaires
et on était quand été supprimé il est
arrivé comme ça un peu au dernier moment
comme rassembleur mustapha oui mais
justement comme le disait notre ami
c'est vrai que c'est plus facile de le
commenter après en disant que pécresse
et eric ou non c'est le principe du
commentaire sauf que moi je dirais je
dirais autre chose je dirais que
probablement qu'elle l'a voulu plus que
le plus que bartolone peut-être qu'elle
ne voulait plus en ce sens où maintenant
de l'explication puisque on n'arrête pas
de nous rabâcher maintenant que on
l'avait dit avant on le dit encore plus
maintenant que finalement bartelone
était quelqu'un qu'on était allé
chercher et non pas quelqu'un qui est
venu comme pécresse leurs effets et que
en allant le chercher finalement on a
considéré que c'était le meilleur
candidat c'est qu'elle soit deux
candidats font amende
voilà donc voilà j'ai donc cette
hypothèse que pécresse le voulait
vraiment pour éliminer au chant aussi au
sénat
donc c'était presque par dépit que par
conviction au quelqu'un il a fait une
campagne semble-t-il qui est quand même
une campagne honorable mais on n'arrive
pas à ce stade et à ses scores sans
avoir fait la campagne qu'il a fait
de là lui est imputé la défaite une
phrase maladroite plus que maladroite
d'ailleurs
sur le fond moi je crois pas d'autant
plus que ce qu'ils voulaient imputé
c'était en gros vous êtes copine de
série a prononcé cette phrase au radon
et non pas la candidate de la race
blanche simplement c'est mal dit s'est
mal exprimé
et dans ces temps à la fois troublé
compliqué en or il faut de la
clarification l'a pas été mais c'est
plus de la maladresse que le désir c'est
maintenant lui a imputé la défaite sur
ça je crois pas moi c'est plus sain que
je vois la campagne quand on le veut
vraiment ça me fait penser à josselin
j'ai l'impression que je sois le voulez
- à l'époque chirac
donc quand on veut gagner on se donne
les moyens et à ce moment là j'ai le
sentiment que pécresse était plus
désireuse de l'actuelle ne l'était pas
barton c'est une hausse qui devrait
démissionner de la présidence de
l'assemblée nationale
oui si c'était s'il était cohérent avec
tout ce qui se dit ou ce qu'ils votent
depuis l'accession normal premier à
l'elysée oui il devrait bien évidemment
qui devrait démissionner il n'y a aucune
raison
c'est elle c'est un truc de république
bananière de doses est en pleine débâcle
enfin je dirige il a quand même pris il
a perdu une région qui était à la gauche
depuis 17 ans il a perdu avec n'est pas
des maladresses et qu'une volonté de
monter les gens les uns contre les
autres de façon ostensible et
scandaleuse il a perdu et tant mieux
mais après osé dire le soir des
résultats et je remets mon poste de
président de l'assemblée nationale à la
rentrée n'ont pas leur n'a pas débuté
oui on réduire handibat y entrer il y
aune il est honnête il est normal il a
compris le message n'est pas du tout je
remets mon poste devant mes amis de la
semaine nationale du groupe ps
mais c'est une galéjade à face et on
arrive dans le domaine de la politique
grotesque voudraient quand on parlait du
mc anglais des droits pour votre
bartolone demande mais c'est absolue
pour le coup je fais d'accusation pour
le coup je serais d'accord c'est
l'histoire était comme taverne vous avez
l'air de le décrire c'est pas du tout ça
c'est clairement on est venu le chercher
et il a dit à ce moment là j'ai une
condition je vis
seule condition c'est que si je suis élu
j'abandonne trust par définition en
revanche si je suis pas oui je reviens
c'est pas très courageux combat mais
c'est ce qu'on donne s'est pas fait
cours à ce que maintenant il va
démissionner la députation s'il y avait
c'est internationale quand on se
présente aux suffrages des ébats des
français et qu'on perd on perd et puis
c'est tout alors qu'ils n'avaient pas
les mêmes délais que sur la période
un scrutin il est député doit
démissionner non non non non la
présidence de l'assemblée qu'il apprécie
alors c'est tout député non c'est un
dépôt députés ont décidé bien évidemment
mais pour l'instant il reste encore une
majorité de députés de gauche donc les
dons qu'il est il est son souci mais ont
peu de temps en temps morales est ce que
ce n'est pas une obligation mais non
content morales qui devrait démissionner
on peut avoir un petit peu d'honneur un
petit peu de morale on comparait du
courrier resté vague
est-ce qu'il devient des lycées dans les
situations de nous vivons depuis des
décennies qui l'avait pas il n'y a pas
de raison démissionner elle s'est par
contre si on se projette vers ce
qu'attendent les français de la
politique dans l'avenir
oui il devrait avoir la décence de
partir c'est une évidence maintenant
encore une fois oui pour les français
ont dit pas si ça vous a échappé mais
enfin je pense que non au premier et au
second tour ils ont dit ça suffit
7 millions de personnes qui votent pour
le front national quand même ça fait du
monde
donc à un moment donné qu est ce que
veulent les français je ne pense pas
qu'il y ait 7 millions de fasciste en
france et six tentes est d'ailleurs
normal ram nationalité fascisme ça
serait ok le gars faudrait interdire ce
parti parce que quand on entend le
premier ministre nous racontait que j'ai
jamais le front national gagne est ce ça
la guerre civile
c'est quand même à tomber par terre
souvent parler en face les français
veulent qu'on se tourne vers l'avenir et
l'avenir ce n'est pas des arrangements
de coca c'est pour faire en sorte
il faut pas surinterpréter tout cela
c'est vrai que c'est pas dans les
coutumes dans les moeurs
en france ça se produit dans des
démocraties qui sont conçus autrement en
grande bretagne par exemple ou encore
aux états unis quand on perd un scrutin
quel qu'il soit quand on est un élu et
bien on démissionne et on quitte parfois
même assez souvent la vie politique
cela dit s'agissait pas du même scrutin
du même type de scrutin bon il ya un
scrutin qui qui qui composent un organe
politique d'un côté les législatives et
un scrutin qui composent un organe
administratif de l'autre conseil
régional s'est pas sur le même plan une
avec l'image de la politique mais il
n'aurait il n'en reste pas moins que
c'est une pratique courante donc voilà
dans des démocraties voisines et à ce
compte là je pense qu'on s'en porterait
pas plus mal si nos élus s'appliquer à
eux-mêmes 7
cette règle est un petit peu dangereux
ce que vous n'êtes pas ce qu alors si on
admet l'idée que ce soit pas sur le même
plan c'est à dire que donc les résultats
ne sont pas interprétés sur le même plan
non plus donc les rethel régionaux il
résultats des noms mais donc rien n'est
grave alors c'est pas grave si c'est pas
grave si c'est pas grave pour barcelone
d'avoir perdu un scrutin visant à
administrer la france par rapport à un
scrutin qui viserait qui viserait à les
gouverner
alors pourquoi est-ce qu'on s'affole des
résultats de ces régionales ça n'a
aucune importance si je vous écoute
c'est pas grave c'est ainsi un scrutin
qui compte pas c'est un saint ce potin
pour du pense pas avoir à homs alors
c'est pas pareil ça pas la même
importance
c'est non ça c'est pas que ça n'a pas la
même importance et que ça se joue sur
deux plans différents allant admettons
dans le commentaire que j'ai deux plans
différents que sept points de vue que
ces comparaisons ne caressent 7 millions
de gens qui n'enraye c'est vrai vous
pouvez admettre que les gens n'ont pas
voté pour dire tout bartelone
démissionner de la présidence de
l'assemblée
on peut juste voilà après après qu'il eu
facile face pas cette approche
personnelle ce qui fait parler de morale
ce qu'il faut quand même admettre ce
qu'ils ont voté non à barcelone c'est
tout à la personnalité de barcelone cccb
bartelone c'est pas stéphane mensonge
jean charles lajoie l'histoire sont
leurs rites et les alliances au cloud
c'est peut-être cesser l'effusion enfin
c'est d'aider les franciliens ont refusé
cours scandaleux me prononcer dans le
9-3 contre la race blanche
essayons de monter les gens les uns
contre les autres en dix ans et
peut-être aussi l'agneau savais que je
sais pas avec le pc avec en place le
certainement pas n'ont pas n'ont pas
vous non plus ouais je crois sincèrement
que les français qui ont voté contre
barcelone n'ont pas voté sur le fait de
savoir s'il allait revenir au perchoir
après encore une fois ces deux choses
différentes et je continue à le dire
la règle était connue c'est à dire qu'il
allait revenir ou peut-être que c'est dû
au sacro saint principe de ce qui est
entendu avant qui doit pas être
appliquée on prend le cas de le drian au
ministre de la défense
il ya des principales radios nationales
prennent part dont l'âge volet ben
justement après les élections il ya
toujours derrière est toujours qu'il
avait décrit qui n avaient qu ils sont
plus tristes on était au qg des
républicains donc là c'était plutôt
bonne ambiance
hier soir la droite francilienne a fêté
la fin de 17 ans de pouvoir socialiste
les militants ont pu savourer leur
victoire
enfin j'ai envie de dire et ça fait
plaisir de voir que les franciliens font
confiance à valérie pécresse et
l'ensemble de son équipe et à son
programme et qu'ils ont ils ont été
convaincus par valérie pécresse mais
qu'ils ont également désavoué la gestion
socialiste des 17 années passées
pourtant le score était très serré à 21h
hier soir la prudence était de mise dans
ce café parisien où journalistes et
militants attendaient les résultats du
second tour au qg des républicains les
sourires commencent à apparaître aux
fenêtres
enfin peu avant 22 heures valérie
pécresse vient annoncer sa victoire cher
francilienne cher franchir
j'aime notre région mais je sais que
vous attendez désormais non pas des
déclarations d'amour mais les preuves
d'amour et bien dans les six prochaines
années nous allons tout donner pour
l'île de france et vive la france
la tête de liste yvelines valérie
pécresse remporté 44 % des suffrages
devant son adversaire principal de ce
second tour le socialiste claude
bartolone crédité de 42% des voix
dans cette triangulaire le fn arrive
troisième avec 14 % les républicains
remportent donc la région avec une
avance
très restreinte bien sûr on est
extrêmement content que les électeurs
aient choisi vraiment de faire le choix
du changement c'était pas évident c'est
serré et donc ils ont opté pour valérie
pécresse et je reprendrai tous
reconnaissants maintenant il faut être
clair et pas de triomphalisme n'est bien
sûr content fêter cette victoire comme
il se doit mais va falloir ne pas
décevoir derrière pas le temps de se
reposer
valérie pécresse deviendra
officiellement président de la région la
plus peuplée de france ce vendredi lors
du conseil d'installation avec un
objectif clair faire de l'île de france
la première région d'europe un objectif
qu'on doive atteindre tous ensemble sans
oublier les habitants d'île de france
sans oublier aucun de ces territoires
c'est l'enjeu qui est devant nous c'est
aussi le message que nous avons entendu
et je l'aiderai je l'aiderai avec tous
les parlementaires d'île de france et je
l'aiderai avec la sensibilité
particulière qui est la mienne pour le
territoire
en 2010 la candidate de l'union de la
droite et du centre avait perdu face à
jean paul huchon avec un écart de plus
de 10 points
hier soir elle tenait sa revanche ce
qu'a dit valérie pécresse tout à l'heure
lors de sa conférence de presse je suis
libre
exemple des camps des clans des parties
je crois que c'est ce que les français
attendent aujourd'hui une nouvelle façon
de faire la politique qui tient dans
l'action et l'intérêt général pour
certains le dérapage de bartolone à
trois jours du scrutin final où il avait
déclaré que sa rivale défend d encre
versailles neuilly et la race blanche
lui aurait coûté la victoire
la bêtise de la traité de versailles à
jouer on va se réunir à versailles
et après ça d'un
moi personnellement j'ai été élu
conseiller régional donc voilà que m
évidemment on se remette au travail très
vue c'est une campagne très rude
vraiment j'espère qu'on va en tirer tous
des leçons parce qu'il ya encore il
fallait des expressions qui ont été
utilisés surtout entre les deux tours
qui n'étaient pas dignes avec 121 sièges
au conseil régional d'aleri pécresse
remporte cette région phare de 12
millions d'habitants
elle devrait quitter son poste de député
des yvelines dans les prochaines
semaines voilà est-ce que vous avez
besoin de preuves d'amour d'amour penser
que ça va changer des choses d'ailleurs
une élection de plus oui oui ben
politiquement non des places de stéphane
c'était une élection importante ça
paraissait de activement vous faire dire
des choses qu'il ne dit pas à gouverner
une région c'est une méthode à la base
installée vers l'est une région
extrêmement important le programme de
gauche avait rien à voir du programme de
droite sur les investissements sur le
noeud des les transports sur sur
l'écologie sur le grand paris veulent
c'est vraiment et c'est ça qui est
intéressant dans la démocratie c'est que
les gens ont choisi au delà la
personnalité de pécresse ou de bartolone
ils sont choisis ont quand même entre
deux programmes qui n'avaient rien à
voir donc au mois d'août c'est très sain
et ça va donc voilà véritablement
changer les choses pour le bras chefs
d'entreprise par exemple comment moi je
les entretenu sur le dossier de
l'apprentissage qui est un dossier très
important sur le terrain et elle est
complètement un panier de cette notion
de remettre en route toute une
génération au boulot et l'apprentissage
qui est complètement perdu dans notre
pays doit être remis en question or
l'apprentissage est très largement sous
l'autorité des régions donc là je crois
qu'elle a
étaient tout à fait conscients de cette
nécessité surtout en ile de france de
remettre de quantité de jeunes dans le
goût de l'apprentissage pour leur
apprendre un métier et c'est pas avec
les emplois créés par des socialistes
que ça va marcher qu'il faut vraiment
remettre enfin mettre les jeunes au
boulot à travers l'apprentissage
là il faut changer complètement la donne
d'ailleurs son apprentissage mais c'est
un autre dossier dans lequel je peux
vous parler pendant des heures mais en
tout cas elle est consciente de la
nécessité de changer les choses
cette affaire dans le design des grandes
réformes du quinquennat de nicolas
sarkozy c'était la fois mme pécresse sur
les universités 7 pouces un petit goût
je ne suis plus sceptique
wang faible s'est présenté comme encore
aujourd'hui d'ailleurs cette somme il
faut réformer l'université au mois
d'août 2007
non non je suis très sceptique il y
avait il y avait évidemment quelques
éléments positifs sauf que ça a été une
espèce globalement à une espèce de tour
de passe passe qui a pour résumer les
choses en les caricaturant sans doute un
peu qui a permis à l'état de se
désengager si vous lui en disant ça y
est maintenant vous êtes autonome
débrouillez vous pour trouver de
l'argent sauf que on a à peu près les
mêmes structures qu'aux états unis
d'amérique ont nous permet de créer des
fondations mais on n'est pas aux états
unis d'amérique
c'est à dire que récolter de l'argent à
côté c'est très compliqué ça s'apprend
et ça c'est un métier s'apprend et ça se
paye très cher pour payer les gens
compétents qui savent le faire et ça
désigne la série peuvent pas le faire
savoir procès d'intention le concernant
puisque après tout elle veut des preuves
d'amour moi j'attends que des preuves
tout court on a vu les changements de
majorité dire des choses lors d'un
programme lors de on a effectivement des
ambitions on a souvent des à dire des
choses et puis dans la réalité des faits
on voit bien que ça peut ça peut se
manifester attend des preuves tout court
est essentiellement au niveau des
associations et du sport en particulier
voilà on a vu en d'autres lieux en
d'autres domaines des restrictions
budgétaires sont déjà là celui ci bat
pas pour dépenser l'argent pour jeter
l'argent par les fenêtres ce serait se
serait donc le cas que c'est dépenser de
l'argent de séance à où j'attends des
preuves parce qu'on l'a entendu sur sa
carte au discours voilà donc des preuves
d'amour elle en aura moi je suis prêt à
lui faire plein de bisous êtres humains
pour l'affection qu'on peut lui porter
un titre personnel simplement des
preuves réelles on les attend et on va
passer aux résultats nationaux mais
auparavant je propose de regarder
quelques réactions ses résultats en
ligne de france 2 michel laugier par
exemple s puis celle de jean michel
fourgous et pécresse s'impose dans
beaucoup de villes
alors certes le réalise aussi des scores
importants dans les villes tenues par la
gauche notamment aux aiguilles en cours
à la dernière et attrapes et je dire ce
sont des scores tout relatif qu'il faut
regarder puisque là aussi si je regarde
les résultats de 2010 les scores étaient
beaucoup plus importants puisque c'était
beaucoup plus de 70 pensent on était
presque à 80% des résultats pour jean
paul huchon
donc on voit bien que la l'électorat de
gauche s'effrite au niveau de
l'agglomération de saint quentin
écoutez je pense que madame pécresse est
la plus une culture économique
elle sait elle sait attirer les talents
elle s'étire et les capitaux elle elle
prend pas des mesures idéologiques
contre le monde de l'entreprise
donc elle est capable de créer un climat
de confiance de restaurer aussi un
climat avec l'europe parce que la région
ne profitait plus des aides européennes
parce que l'europe et socio libéral
nous on va pouvoir construire des
projets région département qu'est ce qui
beaucoup plus fructueuse parce qu'on
avait beaucoup de mal à travailler avec
eux et je compte sur mon âme pécresse
elle l'a dit dans sa campagne pour que
vraiment rétablir la justice l'équité
entre les gens entre les communes
et puis surtout voilà retrouver un
niveau d'investissement mais mme
pécresse qui connaît le monde économie
qui connaît le monde de la r&d recherche
et du développement
savoir sur quel secteur vous allez
investir c'est très important il faut
comprendre la recherche et je viens moi
je lui fais totale confiance en tout cas
et je suis très heureux de son arrivée
bien sûr à la tête de l'île de france et
peut-être une réaction de gauche la
réaction du maire de trappes guy
malandain la participation aux élections
c'est un geste citoyen qu'il faut faire
au maximum mais on a on a 10% de plus de
2 de votants et quand je regarde la
moyenne du taux d'infection ou du taux
de participation ce qui est une chose
dans l'eau sans fin on est toujours
entre 40 et 45 ici la trappe
si je regarde la ville avant de regarder
l'extérieur 1 d'abord une mobilisation
des habitants de suzon 8 500 votants de
plus que lors du premier tour
et deuxièmement une réaffirmation des
fois républicain philosophiques et
politiques de la majorité de la
population puisque on est à 61 8 pour la
ligue 2 à 10 de bartolone qui correspond
à l'union de la gauche et donc j'en suis
satisfait pour la pile de trappes et ça
nous encourage à continuer l'action
politique que que du que nous menons
voilà chacun voit midi à sa porte
comment il est très content parce que ça
a bien voté à trappes parfum dans un
sens on peut se satisfaire du taux de
participation entre elles même s'il a
augmenté au 2e tour et il demeure encore
à 70% au premier il est passé à 60
d'abstention voilà donc je sais pas si
on peut s'en contenter simplement
ce qu'on remarque souvent pendant 7 à 2
d'élection c'est que tout le monde est
satisfait effectivement alors justement
n'ont pas pas vraiment puisque au soir
du deuxième tour
tout le monde a dit ben nous on n'a pas
de quoi être satisfait c'est eux c'est
pas il n'ya pas de quoi pavoiser
grandmont freddy françois hollande c'est
vrai que le fn n'a pas gagné une seule
région
c'est vrai qu'on peut pas dire que ce
soit une victoire formidable des
républicains et c'est vrai même si là
s'il y avait résisté la gauche quand
même perdu beaucoup de régions donc est
ce que c'est une élection dans laquelle
tout le monde a perdu
non mais non mais non faut quand même
pas il faut pas exagérer d'abord on en
vient de minutes
valérie pécresse c'est une belle
victoire donc quand on gagne une région
comme l'île de france lève tout à fait
de quoi se réjouir donc là c'est évident
c'est une victoire elle peut triompher
elle peut elle peut pavoiser donc donc
ça c'est clair
les autres régions qu'elle soit à droite
ou à gauche il a aucun problème et ils
ont gagné quelques fois que ce soit à
gauche ou à droite pas très peu mais ils
ont gagné 2,2 à la loyale etc
restent quelques quelques régions qui
pose problème sur l'élection de
d'estrosi vecd xavier bertrand ou là
effectivement il n'ya pas de quoi
triompher ni d'un côté ni de l'autre et
ni du troisième d'ailleurs parce que
c'était effectivement un truc un peu
bizarre mais c'est à part ces deux
régions l'ailé des résultats c'est une
élection classique démocrates nous
avions tous les commentaires des
responsables politiques ont été très
mesuré ville pour des raisons que je
m'explique absolument pas je parle d'une
sorte de 2,2 des primes de culpabilité
mal placé c'est à dire que maintenant ça
va être la grande mode on fait de la
politique sans en avoir l'air on
s'excuse d'être élu on s'excuse de
prendre une décision on s'excuse d'être
à droite on s'excuse d'être à gauche
valls ce matin s'excuse d'avoir dit que
l'habit nation le d'enlever la
nationalité des terroristes était une
bonne idée
tout le monde passe son temps à
s'excuser de ce qu'il a fait de ce qui
va faire etc
on nous a encore une fois les gens qui
voient encore plus perplexe qu'il
n'était avant les élections et je pense
que la prochaine fois c'est pas 7
millions de gens qui vont voter pour le
front national seul savait des millions
ce qu'elle janvier mais qu'est ce que
c'est que cette classe politique
qui n'est plus à l'abri mais on ira
peut-être tout à l'heure sur les
conséquences mais quand même c'est comme
une élection rouhia comme le rappelait
mustapha quand même 50% d'abstention
enfin donc amorti cac 40 + wii au
premier tour 50 50 et au deuxième tour
quelque 40 42 c'est quand même beaucoup
où on a voté plus tôt contre quelque
chose que pour des candidats donc c'est
vrai que non ils n'ont pas de raison
d'être
moi je pense que il a faim il n'ya pas
nécessairement matière à se réjouir et
j'ai plutôt compris la réaction des
dirigeants politiques au soir des
résultats du scrutin si six mois le vrai
vainqueur moi me semble-t-il c'est le
front national qui oui contrairement à
ce que laissaient ce deuxième tour qui
ne cesse de progresser dans votre une
progression quasi constante avec
quelques 2 2 petits accidents depuis
1984 mais sa progression est fulgurante
plus de voix pour cent moins de votants
encore plus il ya ya et puis alors deux
vaincus j'en sais rien mais bon il ya
une victoire je suis d'accord avec ce
que dit jean charles symboliquement
forte en ile de france nord pas de
calais picardie paca évidemment le jeu
était à savoir peut-être revenir après
ça n'était pas biaisé mais enfin voilà
bon le drian qu'on se réjouir par
exemple il a magnifiquement gagné il a
très bien gagner mais où joue qui est
bien là de quoi des tribus guérir la
victoire du côté du côté gauche
évidemment on voit à quel point le jeu
triangulaire vient quand même troublé
troublé rebattre les cartes regardez ce
qui se passe pour la gauche dans la
région centre et en bourgogne franche
comté avec un front national à 30% et au
dessus et on voit de la gauche
finalement ne l'emportent que d'une
course rapide grâce à la présence du
front national au second tour donc je
pense que si l'une des explications de
ces mines défaites
dimanche soir c'est le fait qu' il ya un
troisième larron qui s'est introduit
dans le jeu qui fait pratiquement jeu
égal à verser deux autres et qui va
falloir faire de la place et que les
choses ça c'est très intéressant
poser la question de savoir ce qu un des
grands perdants
en tout cas dont deux régions le nord
pas de calais et le dakar il ya plus de
socialiste à l'assemblée régionale 1 0 à
caen se retrouve là dedans un bipartisme
nouveau front national contre les
républicains c'est quand même un profil
sur deux régions très importante
économiquement et en termes de nombre de
populations qui va prendre en servir
dans les deux années qui viennent
de véritables laboratoires parce que là
le bipartisme a totalement changé
alors qu'est ce qui va se passer parce
qu'évidemment pensez bien que les gens
du front national vont pas comme ça
disparaître des écrans ils vont
continuer en région à faire un travail
probablement spectaculaire doit exister
mais ceux ci ne sont plus là donc vous
nous sommes dans un nouveau but partisme
c'est vraiment pas celui qui était prévu
dans le cadre de la 5ème république dans
le cadre de la constitution
mais pourtant il existe dans deux
régions très important des rêves et ses
portes les circonstances c'est là et
avec avec peut-être randy reviendra tout
à l'heure des présidents qui vont
peut-être tenir compte du fait que ils
ont été élus aussi par des voir qu'ils
ne venaient pas piquée des vers il ya
plus de conseillers
fn que de moi j'avais j'avais de
réflexion moi j'avais le sentiment
contraire que chacun défende et sa
posture et donc par définition avait
trouvé du positif même dans ce qui
pouvait paraître comme étant des
défaites pour eux donc chacun à trouver
des arguments à penser que le ni ni
était plus important que le nom apparaît
après bâle a ramené tout le monde à
trouver des arguments finalement pour
défendre son coin et c'est une posture
qu'on peut comprendre moi j'avais une
autre explication j'avais le sentiment
qu'ils avaient plus de la pudeur que
finalement de la crainte qui a pu y
avoir dans les affrontements de la
pudeur face aux événements qu'on a vécu
juste avant et en même temps le
sentiment que c'était presque une
élection qu'on allait qu'on avait envie
d'enjamber mais que le fn a fini par
pardon dont le fn a fini par donner une
dimension nationale qui fait qu'on sait
plus s'arrêter qu'on aurait voulu parce
qu'on a eu et tout le monde avait la
tête aux présidentielles et que c'est
presque un galop d'essai et que toulon
était dans le coup d'après c'est à dire
que alors même le gars du même le coup
de laisser tomber deux régions c'était
presque et ce probablement il n'est pas
seul mais la pudeur d'une part à pas
triomphé trop mais pourtant dans une
posture de vainqueur pour tous parce que
matière à dire qu'ils avaient gagné et
en même temps l'envi d'enjamber
rapidement cette élection parce que au
regard des compétences de la région au
regard de l'enjeu des régions je suis
pas persuadé qu' il ya beaucoup de
choses à à trouver de divergent dans les
programmes des uns aux autres pour qu'on
soit arrivé à la politique culturelle à
new york comme on l'imaginé survient à
ce que dst va dire qu'on passe des nuits
pour la réalisation une tripolarisation
ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire est ce
que est ce qu'il va falloir que les
institutions sont ne favorise pas ça les
institutions sont tout fait pour qu'il y
ait deux grands corps est ce que ça veut
dire alors il ya deux possibilités soit
il ya de nouvelles alliances pour
retrouver deux camps si on ressent dans
ses institutions
soit il faut changer d'institution
partir je ne sais pas même la
proportionnelle pour pour voilà coller à
la réalité politique
qu'est-ce que vous pour ce qui peut se
passer qu'est-ce qui est la vôtre est il
faudra faire patrice vous avez vous dit
de toute façon le jeu en 1958 a été
vraiment c'est l'une des des grands axes
philosophique de la deûle a construit un
gain de 58 incessament ces deux de
simplifier le jeu politique en faisant
en gros deux camps et la cristallisation
de cette dualité c'est l'élection
présidentielle et puis c'est le scrutin
à deux tours
au premier tour je choisis au second
tour j'élimine le second tour suppose un
jeu d'alliances puisqu'on n'est pas dans
un bipartisme mais effectivement à
l'origine dans une bipolarité de 2-2-2
agrégation deux ensembles qui vont
s'agréger pour le second tour là ça nous
montre que il ya effectivement de la
place désormais pour 3 est la seule
façon enfin la seule façon l'une des
voies à explorer c'est évidemment de
changer le mode de scrutin puisque le
mode de scrutin ne décide pas à la place
des électeurs mais il a un effet très
structurant sur l'interprétation de la
décision du corps électoral
c'est lui qui vient cristalliser le
paysage politique donc en introduisant
de la proportionnelle il peut y avoir de
la place pour trois mais à chaque fois
qu'on parle de ses ambitions de la
proportionnelle alors qu on change on
change totalement de paradigme comme
disent les sociologues mais ont des
regrets voire d'esprit des institutions
et la crainte permanente que tout le
temps rebattues et rabâché c'est de
retomber dans les affres de la quatrième
république
souvenez-vous du hasard que c'était les
magouilles entre partis forcément pas
forcément il peut y avoir un
fonctionnement à peu près rationnelle de
la proportionnelle on voit en tout cas
que ça marche dans certains pays il ya
des traditions très forte voire pas
réseau vous prenez la belgique le
caractère multinational de ce pays il
n'ya pas de nation belge mais il ya une
nation francophone une nation
néerlandophones et puis une partie même
germanophone on peut pas faire autrement
que de pratiquer la proportionnelle
intégrale versement absolument mais les
choses ont pas cessé de fonctionner et
les belges emporte
je sentais très bien et on a alors on va
peut-être venir après sur des courses et
qu'on soit parce que ça fait partie des
conséquences et le front républicain
quand même qu'on a beaucoup critiqué
ça ne marche pas les français n'en
veulent pas ils veulent voilà voter il
n'y a pas qu'une raison que les gens de
droits de vote pour quelqu'un de gauche
des gens de gauche pour quelqu'un droite
or sakon marché est plutôt très bien
marcher parce que l'élection de bertrand
et même celle d'estrosi sont assez
larges
enfin il pas multifonds république et en
l'occurrence il ya eu un désistement du
parti social ce qui est pas un front
républicain ça y'a pas vous n'avez pas
d'alliance le front républicain utt qui
viennent alliance entre les deux parties
ce qui n'est pas le cas du tout dans le
fond reste aussi un bar à front
républicain non c'est un barrage c'est
pas un fonds non mais nous ça a l'air
comme ça mais c'est intéressant mais non
non il ya bien aujourd'hui dans ces deux
régions le désistement des socialistes
en dix ans maintenant à dieu vat
et lorsqu'il c'est alarmant avec vomica
vous avez bien des gens dans ce sens
n'était vraiment pas qu'il fait front
sur la campagne 1 seront c'était de
l'alliance entre les parties il n'y a
pas d'alliance entre les parties et donc
du coup d'ailleurs nicolas sarkozy a
gagné dans son nid et comme il est passé
grosso modo avec lui région trouvait
finalement il est lui dans son mandat
dans son contrat donc sarkozy alors
après on prend ce qu'on veut du bonhomme
sait pas non non c'est simplement avec
ses lignes et moi je pense qu'il ya une
victoire du nombre et pour ce qui me
concerne je ne vois pas de front
républicain est en tout cas pas ni dans
le nord ni en paca on voit bien venue en
alsace que ça ils s'en sont sortis et
les données socialistes sont restés et
tant mieux j'ai une certaine logique
repas se moquer des électeurs fait dire
aux électeurs que le champ il faut se
mettre la tête dans la situation quand
on regarde les votes que les électeurs
on al'impression un électeur annoncé
mardi un type qui est militant du fond
de ce que l'on appelle un militant du
parti socialiste on lui dit des congrès
en paca et dans le nord la droite c'est
ce qu'à new voter à droite
à paris on dit c'est des salopards de la
race blanche
il faut absolument lutter contre eux
dans chaque région c'est différent en
bretagne on dit ah bah là tu peux voter
pour ce dossier mais surtout pas les
soins de gauche pas d'écologie on en a
pas besoin donc juste ps parfaite je
veux dire c'est qu'on se moque d'eux les
lecteurs quoi qu'ils pensent
on décide à paris ou du bon alors là ça
va faire bien ça va faire ceci c'est à
faire cela mais de qui se moque t-on
c'est comme ça qu'on renforce front
national veut dire que la voix
l'électeur n'a plus aucune importance
taxe exactement comme quand la les
français avait brassé nomme les
référendums sa part les décideurs les
électeurs avaient voté non au référendum
mais finalement ça n'a servi à rien
parce qu'au bout d'un an on a dit que
finalement c'est oui ah ben on va très
bien et là c'est pareil ils votent
certains à gauche d'autres front
national tu aimais ces panneaux on s'en
fout de ce que vous votez façon ça sera
un mec de droite et c'est monsieur valls
qui décide mais je viens macherez
électeurs socialistes seraient furieux
il ya un aspect fondamental qui est
qu'il faut signaler c'est que le
problème me semble-t-il c'est que les
choses n'avaient pas été annoncée à
l'avancé du moins du côté du parti
socialiste la moindre des choses
en effet ali ziri un peu il faudra
laisser s'est regroupé pas clair c'était
vraiment pas clair la moindre des choses
ce serait que les chaque chaque
formation politique annonce à
l'avancement la dent kelly de thèse je
me retire ou en fusionnant et c'est là
ça n'avait pas été le cas ce qui a donné
l'impression le sentiment en effet d'une
petite manipulaient
personne victoire qu'il vaut mieux voter
à droite il dansait la guerre civile
enfin les entrées sauf que ça pose entre
le sérieux ces gens là vous disiez tout
à l'heure qu'au premier tour où
finalement on choisit de tourner par
définition ne votera pas le tour c'est
carrément abandonné au premier donc ils
n'ont pas le choix que de dire voter
pour nos premiers tours et donner une
consigne de vote au second tour et la
réflexion que j'ai moi finalement c'est
une fois ça n'a pas trop compliqué en
tout cas pour moi c'est que on passe
notre temps à dire que les parties que
les partis politiques ne servent à rien
et quand finalement ils veulent imposer
entre guillemets l'on va dire le leur
autorité leur autorité j'entends
partizan a demandé quand on s'adresse au
peuple et qu'on leur dit nous partis
politiques de droite ou de gauche
on considère que pour le bien de la
nation pour l'intérêt général on est
prêt à s'asseoir sur une région on est
prêt à s'asseoir sur quelques principes
parce qu'on ne veut pas laisser tomber
des principes beaucoup plus fondamentaux
à ce moment les partis politiques
prennent leurs responsabilités et là on
considère que c'est une déroute que
c'est se moquer du monde
on le dit clairement on dit qu'il ya des
choses qui sont qui sont accessoires il
ya des choses qui sont fondamentales et
quand un parti politique prend cette
décision au risque finalement de laisser
tomber ses petits intérêts électoraux
finalement un court terme devant
l'essentiel bah je considère qu
effectivement parti politique prend ses
responsabilités a au moins fait acte
d'autorité et demander ensuite de voter
mais les gens ne sont pas obligés de
l'hexagone krasnik si on se dit qu'à un
moment donné
voilà les régionales on en a fait des
caisses les régionales à mon avis on a
fait beaucoup c'est en ça que je
remercie le front national parce que
finalement servi de la lumière sur une
élection que personne ne m'avait frappe
pratiquement envie de regarder à part
visiblement jean charles qui a bien
regardé tous les programmes dans le
détail pour savoir s'il devait
retranchant sera bleu ou jaune
et si éventuellement les coalitions au
sommet au sol mais assez juste pour
caricaturer un peu bas par le mépris
dans la caricature parfois dire des
choses un peu notamment
pour dire les choses autrement devant un
parti du tisserand non pas une posture
pour le coup mais décide d'abandonner ce
qui peut parler c'est quand même
courageux si j'ai lancé une étude pour
albert vous le dis c'est que j'en
entends les militants des militants
c'est de s'asseoir sur 7 millions de
gens qui ont voté front national et
dépendent pour des andouilles et de dire
à ceux qui ont voté pour soi en bas
surtout ne le fait plus il voit c'est la
guerre civile
mais séoul avait voici là le coup
d'envoi après les larmes qui coulaient
dans grand guignol je comprends excusez
moi qu'on retrouve comprends pas mais ce
que tu comptes monde en fanfare mais non
je comprends pas ensuite me souderait
surnommé il n'a pas tort de dire qui
avait lancé avec merci la crise
accessoires son choix vous disent merci
parce qu'il peut y avoir il ya des
hommes politiques en aucun cas les un
peu les partis politiques sont faits
pour dire à qui et pour qui il faut
botter propos d'une gare
je ne dis pas qu'il n'a pas toujours eu
la vocation d'un parti politique n'est
pas de dire voter at pour telle personne
ou pour telle est la vocation d'un parti
politique est de définir une ligne
politique et imposer les idées et bons
sens et une idée c'est une idée majeure
il s'est dit c'est la négation de toute
idée dans la cession n'était pas là d'un
mur appelé à voter chirac
ribard sspa presse bien voilà c'est pas
parce qu'une erreur serait que c'est pas
ça veut dire ça fait une erreur je
répète quelqu'un qui est pro il devient
jure avec cette immonde a toujours
existé non mais je crois que je ne
comprends pas votre analyse des
deux-tiers de dire le fait pas le ni ni
à gagner la cote
tous les analystes disent non celui qui
a gagné en gros c'est hollande c'est pas
de la poésie à je suis pas du tout sûr
selon dégager toujours sur la liste
était derrière le sarkozy bouge encore
en tout cas
mais paul on entendit les muet la ému
parce qu'ils n'avaient pas prendre parti
sur une élection régionale mais moment
ils sont nos terres humides
enfin on sait très bien qu'il était à la
manoeuvre derrière vale c'est sûr mais
honnêtement là ça vous manque pas la
parole d'un président de la république
fédérale n'aura aucune importance alors
pour lui réserver là il n'y a pas de
commémoration donc oui c'est vrai
il a épuisé son crédit de voyages avant
les élections il a plus rien après mais
non vous trouvez pas alors non mais
quand les colonies ni à gagner ça vous
que mais mal à comprendre d'autres
heureusement me concerne très
modestement
j'assume ce que je viens de lire ni à
gagner
par contre ceux qui a perdu encore une
fois hélas c'est la démocratie la vraie
comment peut-on imaginer que pendant les
années qui viennent 6 les socialistes
dans nord et en paca n'est plus voix au
chapitre
c'est absolument incroyable incroyable
ou alors comme ça pour dire qu'il faut
pas que marine le pen gagne mais les
électeurs sont grands ils sont adultes
ils savent de quoi il en retourne j'ai
regardé ce qui se fait dans l'est dans
les régions dans lequel on a gardé trois
candidats la droite est passé les
français marine le pen contrairement à
ce que les parties ont pu dire marine le
pen serait aujourd'hui voilà la grande
gagnante mais quand ils quittent la vie
n'est pas semblable on voit des français
or on leur a dit vous savez on se retire
nous les socialistes aussi jamais marine
le pen passait ce sera la guerre civile
excusez moi c'est une honte de raconter
des choses pareilles
franchement non mais on est d'accord ça
a quand même une portée extrêmement
important puisque dans un an et demi on
va être en 2017 on a les élections
présidentielles qui arrivent qu'est ce
qu'on est en train de faire finalement
parce que faut pas se leurrer on prépare
sa passion pour préparer le fait qu' il
faut pas que marine le pen passe ne
passera pas cessé c'est quasiment acquis
mais et je suis moi je m'élève contre ça
on continue aujourd'hui à s'asseoir sur
7 millions qui veut pour le front
national
et ils votent pas pour le fascisme ces
gens là où ils veulent et ce qu'ils
veulent connaître des génomes
là pour le coup une région longtemps ils
n'ont pas les appeler des lieux de
l'elysée regarder en bretagne toutefois
vous citiez cet exemple des idées quand
même seulement incroyable en bretagne
voilà que monsieur donne le drian alors
que aujourd'hui toute la classe
politique ou presque est vent debout
contre le cumul de mandats eh bien on
dit voter pour monsieur le drian
mais vous inquiétez pas il restera
ministre de la défense et il sera
présent dans la région bretagne au
secours quoi il faut arrêter tous ces
faux semblants
il faut arrêter même sauce bordelaise en
minimes et il faut arrêter tous ces
petits arrangements sessad c'est ça pour
lequel les français sont en train de se
déclarer qu'ils disent stop à ce que
j'entends juste fermeté non mais je dis
juste une chose d'après après je voulais
ça va on parlait de perdants le seul
perdant ses jupes et là dedans juppé m
il a des relations très aiguisé n a
heureusement une photo de bordeaux moche
devrait dire lui pour dit non sinon il
allait parler mais la liste juppé sa
caméra mais non mais hier j'ai un agent
qui est difficile pour la droite ya un
bien un truc vraiment sauf que toutes
ces dames ont dit tout et son contraire
si je peux me permettre les serveurs de
sa relève
mais je parle je parle de vous on est on
reste cohérent tout on reste cohérent
quand vous disiez tout à l'heure que
finalement la tacc concernant pécresse
sur la race blanche de bartolone a fait
perdre avec un cyclone a fait perdre art
absolument
de la même façon tout ce qui est dit à
l'encontre de marine le pen devrait
faire perdre ses opposants et donc
ferait gagner
par définition le pen puisque si le
réseau ghnassia faut redevenir des
champs à dire des inepties la route je
voulais simplement dire que j'ai pas le
sentiment que qu'on oublie les 7
millions d'électeurs qui se prononcent
pour le front national fait que bien au
contraire ce sont eux qui sont au centre
du jeu c'est vraiment pas beaucoup comme
jamais on ne cesse d'en parler et
regardez le ce que les politologues
peuvent appeler pour résumer les choses
la droitisation de l'échiquier politique
en france
ça montre bien que c'est justement ces
sept millions d'électeurs là qui
intéresse tout le monde tout le monde
sarkozy n'a évidemment qui galope après
tant qu'il peut la gauche elle aussi du
moins une partie de la gauche qui en
vient à adopter un discours qui trouble
sur la gauche de la gauche et au delà
donc c'est plutôt l'élément central et
on a vu la jouer à l'occasion de ce
scrutin des régionales et même dans les
scrutins précédents tout au long de
l'année
justement le fait que cet électorat du
front national c'est lui qui capte
toutes les attentions de la part de
ceux-ci prétendre à obtenir des mandats
sais tu sais c'est qu'en fait les
français ont besoin d'une
vélov politique et aujourd'hui c'est une
classe politique
et là c'est la famille le pen dommage on
va pardon justin juste un mot je me
rappelle moi très bien des 18% qu'avait
fait berrou au premier tour des
élections présidentielles en 2007 et
tout le monde était focalisée sur ces 18
% malheureusement en 2012 berrou cette
andouille nous raconte qu'il faut aller
voter hollande
il a raté la marche parce qu'ils avaient
la capacité d'être l'offre politique qui
réellement à verre métal français de
s'exprimer qui reviennent il va se
passer du temps justement lorsqu'il est
tombé sur les conséquences parce que ce
que vous disiez au fond et c'est la
thèse de sarkozy sarkozy est arrivé
partie le soin de premier tour au qg des
républiques en dix ans et qu'on ne me
dise pas ta femme la france n'est pas
une droite
or aujourd'hui contrairement à vous il
ya des gens au parti républicain nkm dit
mais s'il n'y avait pas eu l'oeil on
avait fait le mini maladroit le nord et
la région paca tomber au moins du front
national estrosi qui quand même pas un
type de gauche titrait lundi 10 mai faut
arrêter de courir derrière le front
national c'est comme ça qu'on les fait
monter c'est à dire qu'il ya quand même
vous sentez quand même une révolte forte
contre la contre la wla position est là
et la thèse de sarkozy celle d'une nuit
et celle de la droitisation des
républicains alors estrosi est choisie
est bien forcé de tenir ce discours il
leur fait mal on doit faire abstraction
des gens qui ont voté pour lui
j'étais quand même assez mal parti donc
qu'ils envoient d'avec des petits
signaux à gauche c'est normal c'est pas
très élégant mais disons que c'est ça
peut se concevoir
nkm c'est différent et met en opposition
systématique
moi je la trouve très sympathique j'ai
beaucoup d'admiration pour elle mais ça
me paraît pas anormal qu'elle se fasse
virer du gouvernement des républicains
dans la mesure c'est exactement comme si
manuel valls en tant que premier
ministre avait dit peut passer son temps
à dire qu'il était contre le mariage
pour tous et qui reste premier ministre
on peut pas aller contre la dénommée
hindery doit y avoir par dont il doit y
avoir une délibération mois de février
aux républicains sur la ligne donc là on
la vire avant et la livre
par sarko sur le ni-ni c'est clair et
net elle s'oppose à sa bon en plus alors
je parle pas d'avoir de débat sur la
ligne à cirer du clic ton band mode
février pour le débaucher des
républicains ensuite la et elle est un
peu dans une posture elle se prépare à
se présenter à la primaire parce que de
toute façon l'élection de pécresse est
pour elle une catastrophe pour une calme
objectivement elle a perdu elle
paris paris pécresse gagne la grande
région pécresse va devenir la femme
peule il aura pas gagné parisien cela
dit les votes à paris non affirmé me
pécresse devient la femme incontournable
à droite en ile de france
l'horizon pour ncaa mis les bouchées
enfin la récré ça dégage présenterait
pas non mais bien sûr parce qu'elle est
intelligente elle est elle abandonnée
chaque truc
chacun de ces chacun de ces objectifs
par dont la femme que vous répondrai pas
sur le fond c'est à dire comment il ya
quand même une contestation très forte
de la ligne de sarkozy au sein même pas
sur lui aussi jamais je réfléchirai bien
sûr qui m'écrit qui comptait ce qui l'a
bien remarqué à quel titre s m
estrosi excusez-nous et son lit et
bertrand badie raffarin on peut enfin
ils avaient la part le premier ministre
qui n'a rien fait sous chirac avec ce
président à tous les deux c'est le pire
binôme que la vème république ait pu
connaître pas une réforme est la connaît
oui mais méprisé les gens que je ne
devrais pas te former prix pas mais que
des gens qui sont à l'évidence qui
t'était sarkozy depuis longtemps j
reçoit contre lui ça va je veux dire son
genre bonjour sa réputation des
propositions pour ça toujours il vaut
mieux qu'ils prennent pas position après
il ya voter pour les pour la présidence
notamment
moi je crois que je crois finalement on
a fait abstraction d'une démarche
stratégique dans les deux bords que ce
soit à droite ou à gauche et le front
national en a profité parce que par
définition n'a pas tranché sur un vrai
problème de fond à mon avis donc c'est
le front national pallier la carence de
stratégies des deux grands partis
la recherche de lignes a lieu aussi bien
à droite qu'à gauche
moi ce que je crois c'est que les partis
des deux blocs sont toujours dans des
postures à vouloir faire croire qu'il ya
des grandes différences
donc je suis à droite et j'ai une grande
différence fondamentale avec les gens de
gauche sauf que dans la réalité on se
rend compte que c'est pas si évident que
ça et les gens se disent c'est vrai je
vais encore finir moi et je vais encore
parlé du de l'ump est ce la presqu'île
l'ump est pourquoi parce que je crois
qu'il ya des postures à droite il ya des
postures à gauche
donc il faut que le débat soit tranché
maintenant ou bien on arrive vraiment
deux affrontements ces terres qui est
une idéologie de droite qui affronte une
idéologie de gauche mais réellement sur
des fondamentaux et qu'on le dise
clairement et que les français votent
là il ya plus de front national parce
qu'on se le dise quelles sont les idées
droit question était de gauche et y aura
plus du mps voilà on avait alors fait
voler dit tu va encore nous dire ça avec
70% des français d'après un sauvage dans
les six millions d'électeurs front
national mais mépris des 70 c'est
incongru patrie le tance comme moi 70 %
des français disent qu'ils seraient pour
un accord entre des jambes droites des
gens de gauche sur un pont d'ancenis et
barrez vous gérez suis aussi c'est comme
ça c'est évident encore une fois ce box
que le nombre des sites de quelque chose
que c'est une bonne idée mais bon voilà
je l'évoquais mais quand on voit par
exemple cette pantalonnade de votre ami
raffarin qui dit qui dit maintenant
c'est merveilleux nous allons réunir
avec la gauche pour trouver des
solutions contre le chômage et valls qui
lui envoie un sms ans dont bonne idée
parce qu'avant il ya quatre jours il
savait pas quoi faire contre le chômage
et puis maintenant de 7 millions de gens
qui votent front national et raffarin
comme valls sont des idées en commun
dans l'esclavagé
au moins ma faim si vous êtes un homme
de communication jean charles vous qu'on
va apprendre le b à ba de la com
politique c'est vraiment attendu le
dernier mais non justement donné sur le
fond est ce que vous pensez précis un
certain nombre de gens de bonne volonté
ya vous avez des socialistes plutôt
plutôt sociaux-démocrates sont révélés
sociaux libéraux
vous avez des gens de droite juppé qui
sont pas tentés par l'extrême droite
pour le moins est ce que tous ces gens
là ne pourrait pas se regrouper en
disant voilà des cinq réformes qu'il
faut faire pour la france
on les fait on se met ensemble et on
pensait pas que ça ça ferait baisser le
front national ce que ce que je
comprends pas bien c'est en quoi est ce
que le parti socialiste a besoin de
cliquer ont pour une fiesta besoin de se
détacher probablement de la nature le
sien de l'un d'eux
pas pour l'instant de l'alliance de la
gauche de la gauche et de l'extrême
après cinq mais six érosion de la
majorité
qu'est ce qui empêche sa ferme et vous
vous reposez sur des anciens mais nous
l'assumons il ya de dilution pour que
j'ai dit c'est le paysage politique est
en train de se craqueler changer donc y
aller vers ces personnes devront retenir
conduisant il ya donc des gens qui ont
des solutions contre le cheveu pour
lutter contre le fond c'est comme un
gamin dans leur poche bien sûr concède
qu'il faut c'est très bien de revenir
on sait très bien comment avoir sa
maison de chômage et ben alors les
poussins ps ne fait pas et par six
jeunes hommes habitaient mais parce
qu'ils ont rejoint de personnes par des
gens qui ne les empêcheront de faire ça
n'ont pas besoin de nous passer la
raison de personnes y habitent ainsi non
désirées versée
la droite et la gauche ça n'est pas la
même chose que vous le voulez un exemple
on peut aussi faire éclater et la raison
pour laquelle sept millions de français
sont à l'aise dans ce vote front
national c'est parce que vous avez 7
millions de français qui n'y croient
plus ils veulent bien sûr ni la droite
s'ils en veulent plus ils veulent que ça
marche ils veulent une autre voie hélas
la seule proposition quand leurs fesses
et le front national sur une autre
proposition il y en a certainement
d'autres
le monsieur verrous a raté la marée mais
si vous me voir rater la marche s'est
pas s'entendre sur des réformes précises
alors qu'elle est la probable avant nous
moi je peux vous dire que dans le cadre
de notre secteur d'activité nous avons
des réformes très précises que nous
avons fait valoir et notamment je savais
que vous sur lesquels les jeunes
aujourd'hui pour l'association de
prévention non mais non mais non parce
que malheureusement vous avez très vite
deux postures qui s'opposent
vous avez la posture de la récompense de
l'effort du travail puis vous l'avez
vous avez l'autre qui dure maintenant
soyons solidaires on n'est pas là pour
faire des efforts je vous donne un
exemple samedi même panier j'ai entendu
ce matin et hier matin deux postures
hier matin les employés de la mairie de
la rochelle avait pénétré pas en la
salle devant je me suis pas le temps de
s'arrêter en train d'engueuler le maire
parce que le maire exiger d'eux qu'ils
fassent 35 heures l'autre d'acorn et
donc grosso modo économies pour la ville
3 millions d'euros par an hélas la
déléguée syndicale véhémente dit mais
nous on n'est pas là pour travailler on
n'est pas là pour faire des efforts on
est là pour créer de l'emploi
et si moi mon boulot il permet d'avoir
trois personnes avec lequel je le
partage c'est tant mieux
et là le maire de l'ordre de lui dire
mais madame comprenez il faut quand même
penser aux économique devons faire pour
la vie et à le dire il de répondre j'en
ai rien à faire monsieur moi je suis pas
pro et économie c'est justement elle se
montra une force politique cela sert en
cinq ans ce matin le matin à faire 90 %
des employés de l'usiné smart font
accepter de voter pour revenir aux 39
heures 20 l'oreiller 37
donc ça veut dire quoi il ya bien
monde il ya bien un monde de gauche et
un monde de droite et ses mondes là sont
pas prêts de s'associer et moi je roule
alors tous les jours c'est maladroit
avec des choses à gauche et les gens qui
sont à voir à l'effort et de l'autre ils
ont parlé de moi ils sont fait avoir
dans l'effort et peu compliqué pourquoi
vous avez déjà qu'ils sont favorables à
ce qu'on appelle la finition on partage
désormais le baril vous allez verrait
bien deux visions du monde d'aujourd'hui
veulent désormais la gradation que
jean-charles les socialistes n'ont pas
besoin des voix de droite pour mettre en
place leur projet ni la gauche ni la
droite actuellement ne peut se permettre
de faire quoi que ce soit convient
d'expliquer on a 70 % des gens qui sont
pour cmps entre guillemets 70 ça va être
30 à la marge
15 15 oui à 15 pour soyez voir que des
dégâts si on veut seulement à la droite
il ya 15 ans a posé la question car
chaque fois ces extrêmes qui fait que ça
ne bouge pas et ça ne pourra bouger que
s'il ya vraiment quelque chose qui se
met en place sous forme de allez on va
appeler ça de coalition pour moi
j'apporte des solutions c'était
vachement sens quand vous aviez bertrand
dit c'est notre dernière chance
ça fait ça fait quinze ans que c'est
notre dernière chance
c'est comme à chaque fois qu'il ya des
dégâts non non non mais je pense qu'on
n'a pas encore bu le calice jusqu'à la
lie et qui faudra encore deux secousses
que la valeur est encore secoué cette
classe politique
ça c'est évident mais moi ce qui me
préoccupe au delà de tout cela c'est
qu'il ya 20 millions de personnes qui
sont riches y rester chez elle aucun de
ces deux dimanches alors ceux qui n'y
croient plus et peut-être plus ce que
ceux qui vont qui vont voter
sacré 27 millions là c'est un grand don
sera fait beaucoup merci infiniment à
tous les quatre l'émission est terminée
merci pour cette analyse
et on se retrouve très vite pour nouveau
paf on parle aussi d'autres choses que
de politique